abone ol
bu yaklaşık 10 senedir falan herhalde
böyle konuşuyorum da çıkıyorum Dur bir
yerlere bizde 156 da çok yoğun olarak
yapıyorum bunu sen televizyonlar falan
filan da var ama hala şimdi buraya
gelirken böyle hafiften bir gerginlik
Hem bir kalp palpitasyon da artış ağzım
normalden Bir tık daha kuru avuçlar
hafif ıslak şu anda mikrofon tutmadı mı
senin buçuk alabilir şunu o yüzden
dikkat ediyorum şimdi bunların hepsi
stres reaksiyonları bunlar hep oluyor
zaten bu olmadığı zaman bir sorun olduğu
anlaşılıyor Ondan sonra gelişimini falan
duruyor Bu Sitesi devamlı yaşamanız
lazım tabii başladım öleceğim
zannediyorum ilk bana Mikrofon
takıldığında böyle bir sahnede benden
çıkan her ses şurada her ağzı maçına
çıkan ses
o Ağzımın içi tutkal gibi nasıl
konuşabilir mi ben de şaşırdım tabi
halin ama sonra zaman içerisinde
alışıyorsunuz bu stres dönen reaksiyonun
bizim hayatımızda çok Merkezi bir oluyor
özellikle modern insanlar olarak ben
bugün konseptiyle de birlikte temel
fabrika ayarlarını arasında çok önemli
bulduğum bu stres ve stresle başa çıkma
konumuzun nesiller boyunca başımızın
nasıl belaya sokma potansiyeli
taşıdığını Bugün sizlerle paylaşmaya
çalışacağım stres yok genel geçer
kullandığımız bir tabir basın Arkadaşlar
bu sık sık basmanız gerektirecek bir
sunum olacak Eğer oradan basacaksınız
bizim dilde aslında bir sürü ifade ile
farklı farklı karşıladığımız duyguları
Biz genellikle çok Stres oldum abi de
ifade ettiğimiz için bu tören nedensiz
olduğumuzda çok fazla fark eder mi
biliyoruz ya da onun inceliklerini biraz
Uyan sınavına giremeyen biliyoruz basın
Arkadaşlar her seferinde basında
verirsin arabası Ben biliyorsunuz
insanın fabrika ayarları diye bir şey
anlatıyorum yapıp iki sene önce bir
tatil konuşmasını ilk
bu almıştım sonra 2-3 tane kitap oldu
falan orada beş tane maddemiz var devam
edelim Bu beş madde işte az Yemek çok
hareket etmek iyi ilişkiler kurmak
stresi yönetmek ve sınırları aşmak
şekilde özetleniyor devam etmeyin Bu
basın Zarif ve güzel
bu hareket etme işte az yeme
biliyorsunuz Bunlar tıbbi olarak
ömrünüzü uzatmak için bildiğimiz tıbbi
yeniyorlar diğer insanlarla işte
birlikte olamazsak yalnız kalırsak
erkenden hastalık bölüyoruz Efendim
stresimizi yönetemez sık bugünkü konu
bizi öldürüyor ve sınırlarınızı açmaya
programı canlı olduğunuz için de
protein-protein bizi yavaş yavaş işten
kömür bir şekilde perişan ediyor Ama
özellikle şu son ayar ver ne dedik stres
bütün canlılarda Paylaştığınız Bir
reaksiyonun ismi amacı bizi Darlık
lardan Kurtarmak fakat insan olarak
tabiattan ayrı bir Dizayn yaptığımız
onun içinde yaşadığımız için biz bu
doğal mekanizma açısından bazı sorunlar
yaşıyoruz şimdi bu sorunların temel
kaynağı Türk dileniyorum yemin ediyor
I like geçti
tüm Bu soruların kaynakları muhtelif
fakat bize yaptığı şeyler çok yakıcı
bütün bitkiler ve hayvanlar Hatta
bakteriler stres yaşarken bizim stres
imiz beyin hücrelerini öldürüyor
beynimizi küçültüyor midemizde ünser
yapıyor bağışıklık sistemimizi
darmadağın ediyor bizi kanser ediyor
bize hayatı dar ediyor kısaca şimdi bu
benim pillerinden Robert sapolsky
sakalları ona benzetmeye çok uğraştım
olmadı ya o kadar uzatamıyorum ama çok
güzel bir kitap yazdı Sen ara ben
zebralar niye ünser olmaz diye tabiatta
Stresten Ülser olan tek canlı biziz gibi
gözüküyor çünkü büyük başarı
bu stres oluyorsunuz kafada aşağıda
mideyi de diyorsunuz bunun mekanizmasını
anlayabildiğim zaman Aslında insan
olmanın ne demek olduğunu daire ilginç
bazı sonuçlara varacağız bu vücudumuzda
bir savunma sistemi var bir de onarım ve
dinlenme sistem var Onların dinlenme
sistemin adı parasempatik sistem öbürü
sempatik sistem bunlar bize sormadan
arka planda çalışan devreler ne zaman ki
yemeği yediniz böyle Kısalar yandı
rahatsınız her şey eş dostun evde yavaş
yavaş gözbebekleri küçülür kalbiniz
yavaşlar böyle Gözümüz yatağa doğru
bakmaya başlamıştı o zaman parasempatik
sistem etkiyi devralıyor kestir ve
sindirim sistemi falan da diyorlar mı
Ama ne zaman sen işte bir hayvan
kovalıyor ne zaman Spor yapacağım ne
zaman dedi konuşmasına çıkacağım
sempatik Sistem veriyor arkadan gazı
diyor ki her an bir sorun olabilir
basat'ın önemli bas kortizolü vücudun
daha çok enerji tüketeceği bir faaliyet
durumuna hazırlanmasını sağlayan sayısız
m k
da aynı anda devreye sokuyor Hatta bazı
hormonlar var Hani olur ya Mahallede
kavga çıkar arkadaşınızı dövüyorlar dır
Siz teknik başaramazsınız koşarsınız
kahveye Yahu yok abi dövüyorlardı kahve
bir bazı herkes kalkar ya Aynur Haluk
abi dövüyorlar adrenalin Biz de bütün
organlara gidiyor abi başımız belada her
tarafta gel diz ekleminden beynimize
kadar her tarafı fıstık duruyor başlatan
Haluk abi dövüyorlar ya bu amigdala
beynimizin içinde bir stres tespit
merkezi burası Mesela şimdi ben şurada
Beklerken Gökhan sağ olsun benim
hakkımda konuşuyor bir şeyler söyle
falan bunları söylediği şimdi bak siz
videoda rezil olacağız yine
duygulanıyorum gözlerde olmasın ve bir
tarafından Ne söyleyeceğimi unuttum
edecektim ben nasıl giriş yapacaksın
falan derken ön beynim Yalnızlığa
sürekli muhabbet ediyorum videoda diyor
ki bak bir sıkıntı var Sıkıntı çıkacak
diyor aşağı veriyorsun yani bizim kalp
dalak Böbrek ne varsa içeride ona yavaş
yavaş karşılıklarına başına Allah'tan
konuşma çok zaman hemen buraya çıktık
eve a
ne olacak coşunca hemen komşuluğunda
bulunan beyin ortası hipotalamus
söylüyor ki abi stres var fotoğraftaki
Ne oldu boşver de stres var dışarıda ne
olduğunu bilmiyor ama diyor ki ver
hormonu crh diye bir hormon salgılıyor
kortikotropin salgılatıcı oldu bu hemen
altındaki polise gidiyor bak video stres
ışıklardan öyle söylersen Mümkünse Ace
THY bastı kortikotropik hormon söylenen
Master derecesi veriyoruz öyle bir
hormon çok önemli değil İsmi kan
dolaşımına tabi elinden veriyor
Böbreküstü bezini ne kadar gidip
Böbreküstü bezinin kabuğundan kortizol
diye bir hormon salgılar türü yaptığı
bir sürü diğer işin yanında kortizol ise
çok enteresan bir hormon büyücü bozucu
şu kuruşa getiriyor ve stres durumuna
karşı bir şeyler yapmanızı sağlıyor
bütün hayvanlar aleminde çok işe yarıyor
bize görüyorsunuz bunların Durumları
normal değil Ve bu arkadaşların etkisi
altına girdi en baba hormon korkuyor ve
orada sinir sisteminin her tarafa
gönderdiğin yerlerden
tek başına sırtındaki tüylerin falan ne
hale geldiğini görüyorsunuz av ve Avcı
ilişkisinde bakan bahsettiği gibi mesela
bu koşmaları sağlayan şey aslında bu
sempatik sistem av olan hayvan Avcı
görünce stres olacak ki kaşık kurtulma
şansı olsun avlayacak olan o Avcı
acıtacak ve sinirlenecek ki Açken sen
sen değilsin Onu kovalayacak doğru
raydan çıkma halleri olmasa Mesela bu
avlanma falan dediğimiz süreçte olmaz
biliyorsunuz hayvanlar aleminde Biz
geldik böyle seyrediyoruz Şeyda belgesel
kanallarında hep Ceylan da tutuyoruz o
kaçsın yazık diye seni asla nerede
buzdolabı var öyle abi ne olur kalsın
falan filan Zira Ceylan kaçarsa ya da
Aslanoğlu yakalarsa her içinde stresi
anında bitiyor bakın tamamen kesin sonuç
ya kurtulup da şöyle yapan bir ceylan
gördüğünüz doğru anlamında Bunlar 7
Babam da bunları her gün beni oyalar
Allah kahretsin bu Ceyda Ceylan lık
Olmaz Olsun ben iskandinavya taşınacağım
oradakiler daha mutlu
Yok böyle bir şey yok yok şeylan iki
dakika sonra hafif bir titreyip kendine
geliyor Güzel güzel ot yemeye hoplayıp
zıplamaya devam ediyor ya da vermişti
aslan kaplan aldı kaçırdıktan Sonra
bunları evde Çoluk çocuk aç benden Aslan
Olmaz Olsun kaç gündür bir şey
yakalayamadık falan demiyor güzel güzel
oturup bir sonraki Kısmetini Bekle iki
dakika sonra karnı ne kadar aç olursa
olsun uzun süreli stresi hayvanlarda
görmüyorsunuz insanda 200-300 bin
senedir burada olan bir varlık
Muhtemelen ilk dönemlerde bu
arkadaşlardan çok farklı yaşamıyordu
gibi ama sonra birşey oldu bunlar bizim
eski burada Eskiden nasıl olduğumuzu hiç
Bilen Yok Bunların hepsi de
konstrüksiyonlar inşallah soldaki
değildir Sadece daha güzel gözüküyor bir
değişik gözüküyor ama sonra bir karar
verdik Biz bir şeyler yaptık işte tarımı
bulduk şehirler yaptık sıkıştırmış bir
yerlere yerleştik kendi Kural
kanunlarımızı yöntemlerimiz icat ettik
onun için öyle bir kapandıkça dışarı
çıkamaz
ya da biz size istanbullar her sabah
böyle birşey görüyoruz artık tanıtıyoruz
ankaradakiler yazıp 4 dakika trafik gece
gece trafik var diyorlar Bizim de işimiz
bu tuhaf oluyor 3 saat 50 dakika
beklediğim var benim köprünün ayağına
baktım böyle Ankara'da Üç dakikaya
trafik diyor ve bunu Tanık suya
biliyorsunuz Bunun içerisinde yaşamak
durumunda kalabiliyorsunuz başka bir
sıkıntı da var zaman algısı bu kadar
geniş olan tek canlı biziz bu kadar
geçmiş bu kadar gelecek hatırlayan başka
canlı yok mu hiç bir tavşan görmedik Biz
davranış çalışmalarında Babam bana bu
kadar kötü davranma saydığı Ben süper
tavşan olurdum falan diğer Yok ya da
öldükten sonra başımıza ne gelecek acaba
diyen Bir zürafa ya hiç rastlamadık bu
sadece insanda var çok gelişmiş zaman
algısı geçmiş ve gelecek devamlı bizi
meşgul ediyor niye böyle bir zihin var
tecrübe toplayıp gelecek inşa edelim
diye Tabii ki Ama eğer bu zehir bu yolda
kullanmazsak ne oluyor zaten hayatta
kalma problemde çocuk hiçbir açıklama
ödeme
o istediği kadar uğraşsın hayatta kalmak
için tasarlanmış müziğin başka bir şeye
soruyor çocuğun durumu ne olacak okulun
durumu ne olacak yaşlanacağım
karışacağım acaba falan filan gibi
stresle bu beyni doldurmaya başlıyoruz
kafamız devamlı çalışıyor Hababam ye
ileri doğru hayallerimiz var ama bir
türlü o Hayaller olmuyor çünkü bütün
kanun üstünde mörfi kanunları var Her
şey ters gidiyor bir şekilde planlarımız
bozuluyor o büyük hayallerin hepsi ise
gerçeklerle karşılaşacak tuzla buz bir
hale dönüşüyor ve biz sırf kafasında
kurdukları yüzünden zihinsel stres
üretebilen tek canımız Biz Tan bahset şu
an oturduğu yerde kim bilir neler oluyor
Allah'tan burada biraz eğleniyorsunuz
bir sonuç çıkar çıkmaz ya konuşmaları da
şimdi
bu kredi kartını ne yapacağız Okul
bitince ne olacağız şimdi herkes onu
düşünecek çıkınca İnsanı en çok strese
sokan şey belirsizlik ileri uzanan
zihniniz diyor ki ne yapacağımı
bilmiyorum bilmiyorum dedim bitti o
yüzden planlar programlar kariyerler
garantili Formula En çok sevdiğimiz
şeyler her sabahlar durumu açık bu sabah
ne giyeceğim diye Strese giren Tek canlı
biziz sabah işime nereden gideyim orada
nereden gideyim bunlarla giyim bir Ne
yapayım de güneşte bin tane karar vermek
zorunda kalan tek canlı biz devamlı
kalabalık bir yerde hiç tanımadığımız
insanlarla böyle bir tuhaf ilişkiler
içerisinde yaşayan sürekli biziz ve
şehirli insanın stresi tabiatta
görmediğiniz bir stres buna süren ya da
kronik stres özür işte Bizi öldüren bu
bu Ceylan'ı sadece Aslan öldürüyor
sitesi öldürmüyor ama biz gardrobu
açtığımızda Aslan gelecekmiş le aynı
sistemi devreye soktu muz için seni
Aslan kalıyormuş bir tepki verdiğiniz
için her sabahlar durup bizi küçük küçük
öldürmeye başlıyorum ne yapıyor bu
cortese
ve kortizol her şeyi yapıyor vücudun her
yerine kır başlıyor Yeter ki sıra
tehlikeli ve zor durumdan çıkın diye
canlı dışına takıyor bağışıklık
sistemini başlıyor kan şekerini
yükseltiyor kan basıncını artırıyor
beybi kır başlıyor hoşte mutlu ve
doyumlu sağlayan serotonin ve falan
biraz azaltıyor Ama bu her gün her gün
sürekli olursa ne oluyor Bütün
Kötülüklerin anası Şehirli insanları
öldüren sebeplerin açık ara en birincisi
stres ve strese bağlı hastalıklar işte
hep bunlar yüzünden oluyor yani bu
moralini Bozma moralini bozmak için
anlatmıyorum bunun bir çıkış yolu olmalı
bunu Yönetmeyi öğrenmemiz lazım fan
çaktırmadan arka planda devam eden bu
stresler insanı perişan ediyor Bakın
size Önümüzdeki dönemlerde Önümüzdeki
nesillerde İşler nasıl Sarpa sarabilir
şu anda canlı yaşadığınız birkaç
örnekten bir örnekleme yapalım bugün her
işimizi canlıları ittirerek hallede
biliyoruz yani iki tane cam ittiriyorsun
kapıya yemek geliyoruz artık Öyle bir
dünya var bir 20 Sn 10
O öyle bir şey düşünme imkanımız yoktu
her şeyi dijital dünyadan halleden
insanlara dönüştük bir şikayet var
Özellikle böyle büyükşehirlerde büyük
sitelerde bile korumalı burmalı
plazalarda falan yaşayan çocuklar arada
bir asansörde karşılaşıyorsunuz zaten
komşuluk ilişkileri sadece asansörde
oluyor biliyorsunuz başka sebebi ile
görüşmüyor ne yapıyor farklı puan
diyorsun Siz buradan soruyorsun çocuklu
iyiyim size asla bakmıyor yüzüne bakmış
şekilde çocuklar yüze bakmaya başladı
bakın neden olabilir bu bu Ciddi bir
sorun olarak karşımıza çıkmaya başladı
Biraz önce Gökhan iki tane göz göze
gelme hikayesi vardı Hatırladınız mı Ne
baktın Birader şimdi memeliler aleminde
herhangi bir canlının gözlerine
gözünüzdeki bakın ya sizden Koçak açar
ya da size saldırır Çünkü göz göze
bakmak tehdit işaretidir Zira bütün
Canlılar aleminde özellikle memeli ve
primatlarda missak kavgalar böyle
başladı uzun süre bak
bu takdirde varlar O bakışma bir meydan
okumadır Aslında köpeklere bile uzun
süre bakın huzursuz edersiniz onları bir
şekilde ya havlarlar yapışıyor olur
Fakat insan bu hikaye bir üst aşamaya
taşıya bilmiş
bu anladım Siz oldu Yaklaşık dört dakika
boyunca yapılan deneyler bunu
göstereceğim 4 dakika boyunca özellikle
karşı cinsten biriyle göz göze bakarak
günlük olaylar hakkında geyik yaparsınız
ve sonra bir hoş gelmeye başladı maçı
size ve aşık olma ihtimaliniz çok
yüksektir Çünkü Normalde göz göze
bakınca saldırması gereken beyin der ki
4 dakikadır savaşmadığı mıza göre
la lan Hiç yapmak lazım insanoğlu bu
ruberu iletişimi müthiş bir bağlanmaya
dönüştür aklın Sadece burada kalmasın
Normalde dost sohbetinde Bugün bile
Biraz önce bakayım sizi gözlerini görmek
için aynı sebepten kaynakları Ben de şu
an ön Sıradakiler komple sanıyordum ama
oraya hiç görmüyorum ama kalbim sizinle
göz göze bakarsak Eğer gittikçe samimi
oluyoruz oksitosin falan basılıyor
oksitosin da iki gidiyor evdeki sakin ol
bu çok güvenilir birisi o kadar
bakıyoruz saldırmadı falan teyze bu göz
göze bakma işi çok önemli ama şimdi ne
zaman göz göze bakacağız çocuklar arada
bir ekran var dikkat edin mama
sandalyesi tablet koyma yeri yaptılar
biliyorsunuz ama tablet koyuyorsun da
çocuk yemek yesin diye Bizim çocuk
kamplarında anneler sürekli arıyorlar 51
çocukları alıyoruz annelere varmış
dışarıda arıyorlar anneler bu genelde
sorgusu çocuğum neydi sanki çocuk bir
besi hayvanı
tek başına çocuğu görmemiş Sordu tekrar
Çocuğum ne yedi bir tane anne sordu
şimdiye kadar çocuğum yeni arkadaş
edindim ve mutlu mu diye dedim
Jandarma'ya haber verdi bu kadınları
sıkıntı var Çünkü bütün annelerin tek
amacı var çocuğu beslemek o çocuk nereye
bakıyor Ne yapıyor mutlu mu oynuyor mu
bu dertler tamamen kalkmış kendi sahte
paralarımızın bize düşürdüğü ha çok
komik bundan kaçış yok zihinsel
teknoloji hayatımızdan çıkarmalıyız daha
beter olacak vücudumuzun içine girecek
vücudumuzun modifiye edecek giyilebilir
teknolojiden implant edilebilir
teknoloji geçiyoruz yalnız akıllıca
geçelim arada Helal olan çok olacak ve
bu arkadaşların elindeki bu cihazlarla
ilgili en önemli problemi genellikle ısc
alıyoruz Bu bu ne oluyor musunuz
daha fazla hepiniz biliyorsunuz bunun ne
olduğunu herhangi bir dijital yazılımın
iletişim kutusunun gel ki Sağ ya da sol
üst köşesinde bulunan kapat düğmesi her
şeyi kapata biliyorlar şimdi bu
teknoloji ile uğraşanlar çarpı tuşuna
bastığın zaman her şey kapanıyor ve
dolayısıyla eskilerde pas et vardı
takıyordum Sar sar değerleri Sar sar
geri bir şekilde şarkını bulman
gerekiyor şimdi çocuk MP3 dinle Çünkü
ben de aynısını yapıyorum bu şarkının
başı atla geçmiş Ona göre YouTube
sıkıldım bir sonraki gez devamlı
kapatabilme özgürlüğün var ama normal
hayata geçiyorsun arkadaşı kapatıyoruz
yok
Ne konuşup duruyorsun
Ya anne babanın kapat düğmesi yok
Hababam civciv ediyor öğretmenin
kapattığımız yok o kadar sinirimi
bozuyor ki sonuçta alttakinin falda
kaldırıp Avrupa şampiyonu oluyorsun o
derece dağılıyor seni nerede burada mı
aşağı yapıyoruz yani bir çarpısı olsa
kızcağız belki Alper'le uğraşmayacak O
derece yani onların nasıl bir dünyaya
baktığını anlayamazdı Çünkü bu özgürlüğü
Özellikle bizim kuşaklar hali kuşaklı
bir şey yok ama Bizim Uşaklar çok
anlayamıyoruz bunu fark edemiyoruz la bu
daha yeni içinde şekillendirilen
beyinleri bambaşka bir yönde şekillendi
onlara bambaşka bir şekil veriyor şimdi
Bu hikaye çok hoşunuza gitti uzunca
birden andır çocuklar teknoloji eğitim
Fatih projesi Allah Allah geliyoruz biz
Tabletin içinde koyacağımız Bilemeden
her tarafa tabletlerde attık tablet
çağına geri döndük Ama onun İçi taş
çağından daha ilkel şeylerle dolaşalım
Biz Bu teknolojileri yaparken insanın ne
olduğunu anlama
Bu kaydettiğimiz teknolojileri yeni
insanlarımızın ellerine dağıttık bakın
Teknoloji insanı anlamadan icat
ettiğimiz bir şeyleri daha hızlı daha
çabuk daha bağlantılı falan Belki de
bizim ihtiyacımız bu değil unuttuğumuz
şey insan ve beyni ve Zihnim üç buçuk
milyar yıllık bir ar-ge neyin ürünüdür
ve Muhtemelen bunlar için değil başka
bir şey için yapıldı Biz tabiatta
hayatta kalmak ve gelişip serpilmek
dünyaya yayılmak için çok başka
özelliklerimiz vardı Benim anlattığım
bütün hikayenin özeti biz bu devasa
canlılık orkestrası'nın çok mühim bir
parçasıyız Ama onun ayrılmaz bir
parçasıyız ne kadar kendimizi şehirlere
kapatsak ne kadar kendi suni gıda
larımızı bilmemiz yapsak tıbbi
yöntemlerimiz olsada şu 10 milyon
civarında türden sadece biriyiz onlardan
birçoğu yok olursa bizim hayatımızı
tehlikeye girer Biz yok olursak kimsenin
umurunda olmaz besin zinciri üstündeyiz
biz gitsek
O bizim top oyna yemin ediyorum hiçbir
şey olmaz Dolayısıyla bizim Bu sistemin
içerisindeki yerimiz iyi öğrenmemiz
lazım O yüzden benim türünde tüylü
tutuyor sürekli bunları anlatıyorum
olayı Çözümü nedir efendim İstanbul'da
yaklaşık bir 10-20 yıl yaşasa orada
yazlık almayı düşünmeyen kimseyi
görmedim genellikle Yolda geçen Hocam
dedi ben gideceğim buralardan falan dedi
tabiata açılmak gitmek geri dönmek hep
böyle içimizdeki bir istek bu boşuna
değil o fabrika ayarlarına dönmeye
çalışıyoruz ama illa gidip de bir yerde
bir taşım alıp orada kendiniz ekip içmek
zorunda değilsiniz Hayatımızın her
yerinde tabi adınıza dokunabilmek şansı
var Önce kendimize bakma alışkanlığı
sonra bir canlı dünyaya bakma
alışkanlığı geliştirirsek Lütfen herkes
biyolog olmasın Yiyecek ekmek bulamayız
o zaman bak bizim Elimizden bir şey
gelmiyor ama ne olur bir biyologdan öte
bir merakla canlı dünyaya Tekrar bakalım
ve o zaman orasının bize öğreteceği
derslerin hiçbir sınırın ol
bu teknoloji nasıl değişirse değişsin
nesiller ne ile gelirse gelsin insan
insan olarak kaldı sezonun en büyük
öğretmeni her zaman tabiat olacak Hep
beraber inşallah bol bol oraya Bakalım
Teşekkür ederim